et tous ces problèmes d'eau
la nouvelle crèche ville parc à maurepas
enfin ouvertes des bâtiments qui
accueilleront à terme 78 berceau et 29
professionnels
les parents des enfants déjà présents
semblent déjà conquis par les lieux ça
fait dix jours maintenant qu'on est
entré dans la crèche le retour des
parents est assez positif
ils sont plutôt enchanté par toute cette
clarté cette luminosité et du coup je
laissais effet de grandeur aussi découpé
en quatre sections de couleurs
différentes
un véritable travail a été effectué avec
l'architecte pour retracer le
cheminement de l'enfance et accompagner
pédagogiquement les nourrissons cette
section de couleur bleue tortue bleue
nous l'avons appelée bull d'éveil alors
pourquoi but d'éveil parce que c'est
plus spécifiques à une section de bébé
et du coup ils sont dans un contenant
après le bleu vient le vert afin
d'emmener les petits vers leur
développement
arrive ensuite l'apprentissage des mots
et l'affirmation de soi par le jeu pour
la mairie cette nouvelle crèche
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un projet plus
global
la mairie de maurepas et à l'initiative
d'un grand projet qui s'appelle le
projet génération à la place de la
crèche des oboulo qui était plus dans le
centre-ville de maurepas il va y avoir
une résidence services seniors et nous
avons choisi ce lieu qui est une
ancienne école pour y déplacer la crèche
est au boulot c'était justement pour
avoir une crèche un petit peu plus
grande et surtout plus plus moderne
parce que l'ancien datait des années 80
elle était aux normes mais elle était où
elle avait quand même été un petit peu
vétuste parmi les innovations de
l'établissement l'espace nos élèves il
permettra une fois achevé à un
professionnel et un enfant de s'isoler
et se consacrer à l'éveil des sens pour
un moment tout en lumière et en musique
[Musique]